[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
y pregunta difícil algo más yo creo que
hubiera sido muy difícil ahora el
contexto nos está ayudando muchísimo
sobre todo hablando de argentina y
latinoamérica se está moviendo muchísimo
las mujeres y se han organizado una
manera tal que en la historia
anteriormente no lo habían logrado
entonces el contexto también nos ayuda
para crear un clímax donde nos sintamos
seguras y nos cuidamos entre nosotras es
como la palabra tan conocida sororidad
es lo que ha armado y ha creado esta
complicidad
y poder hablar y decir bueno hablo pero
sé que ustedes me cuidan y somos todas
hermanas y yo creo que eso es lo que nos
ha permitido antes no sé si sí hubiera
sido factible
qué bien lo que decís porque es cierto
que cuando uno habla con toda la pasión
de lo que es significante para cambiar
lo que te callan
sí bueno
en mi caso es un poco diferente porque
está muy visible
pero no sé qué que hubiese hecho en otra
época porque me parece que se sabría no
sé si yo hubiese tenido que hablar o
tratar de expresar pero creo que mi
persona hubiese tratado de ayudar lo más
posible así que bastante parecido por
más de que sea en otra época
pero no la relación con el cuerpo a lo
mejor tu corazón hubiese seguido
pensando pero la conexión con el cuerpo
no lo hubiésemos tenido y por eso la
intención de trabajar el cine como una
convergencia de artes y de formas de
hacer y haber este encontrado lo más
bello que cada persona tiene y poder que
esos sueños de justamente usar el cuerpo
pero
de estar en una situación donde no
entienden francés e inglés y se
encuentran con otras personas y fue el
centro no eran ellas ni yo ni la cámara
el centro de la que todos hacíamos
entonces se vuelve como una obra común y
abstracta donde los resultados son
esperados cuando se trata de cine
directo qué es lo que hago desde con
todas mis películas y ahora puedo
afirmar que este método si funciona solo
el cine experimental que es como vamos a
mostrar lo invisible y que se vuelve a
visible entonces vamos a estos lugares
fabulosos de la naturaleza que nos van a
hacer evocar cosas muy profundas y como
tan grandes y luego la parte ex cinema
ensayo de donde si vamos a adaptar el
método para lo que los personajes
necesitan en este caso para mí era
fundamental que rompan el hielo en un
lugar lejos que vean que el horizonte
que ellas tienen no es ninguna ciudad ni
un país sino que es el mundo porque hay
un factor de unión y es justamente lo
que vamos a hacer junto a lo que existe
sobre él
sobre olvidar qué hermoso y entonces eso
está pasando como decía a nivel mundial
pero yo creo que la argentina juega un
rol fundamental porque se levantaron
nosotros empezamos antes que una ni una
menos y se levantaron así después de un
movimiento 2000 que también se
levantaron las mujeres y nosotras
estamos uniendo todo eso y decimos bueno
hasta basta o irrespeto y basta no
entonces sí
estamos escalando en las posibilidades
de pluralizar la forma de decir las
cosas entonces no hemos hecho un
documental para explicar el crimen hemos
hecho un filme que es del género
documental porque las chicas existen
pero se realiza con una parte metafórica
que hace que la gente interprete cómo se
sienta y como necesite lo que están
viendo
y tengo las piernas agotadas
es muy bien no soy como que te
no me sale la palabra te enriqueces
totalmente es como que te saca ese mundo
que vos tenías una cosmovisión y te
lleva a otro que va mucho más amplio
y no sé cómo que comenzar a venir de un
lugar con un montón de ideas y demás de
acá de montar con un montón de ideas más
que es igual que se pueden aplicar en mi
lugar sobre todo artísticas y cosas que
ayudan un montón y es como eso es como
que te se te abre la mente te cambia el
modo de pensar y a mí me ayudó muchísimo
también eso desde acá de ver que es como
que la gente es más libre se expresa más
a veces y cosas así es como guau qué
hermoso si se puede es claro hay una
diversidad que es aparente no claro
sí bueno lo que dijo al de creo que
estoy bastante igual
la tía dijo algo también oí que dijiste
de irse un poco del lugar y ver otros
horizontes estuvo buenísimo y aparte
sacarnos de donde pasó todo y traernos
acá
se me van las ideas si es que fue las
cosas cuando
además es todo lo que querés hacer que
pone energía para hacer otras cosas
si estar en otro lugar me parece que
estaré en otro lugar como que te
desprendes un poco
te desprendes de
de todo lo de toda tu vida y te venís a
un lugar a centrarte en otras cosas que
no es tu cotidiano que no es lo que
vivís
siempre entonces está buenísimo te
enriquece un montón y yo creo que yo
creo que algo que es súper importante es
que cuando uno conoce otros lugares
otras personas que están todas superan
amables amorosas ellas ellas despiertan
esa energía y esa historia les vuelve y
el intercambio es que uno
se vuelve más libre porque sabe que
tiene puede elegir otras cosas y se
vuelve más equilibrio porque decir bueno
hicimos este proyecto las consecuencias
son altamente positivas son altamente
enriquecedoras entonces no es solamente
cuando hacemos cosas que nos van bien
que tenemos consecuencias la
consecuencia es una definición de la
libertad podemos elegir a partir de
ahora si nos dimos cuenta que
necesitamos hablar otro idioma no ahora
entiende muchísimo más y entre el
proyecto de esta gran beca que se
ganaron en este festival donde el premio
no va para la directora sino para los
para los protagonistas van a poder
terminar la carrera hacer obra danza
estudiar idiomas y ya tienen la
posibilidad de irse a estudiar donde
quieran si quieren o irse y eso estaba
como mucho más lejos antes de hacer el
proyecto entonces bueno nos dimos
enteras a este proyecto y estamos
rodando por el mundo gracias a esto que
vamos a hacer más proyectos y entonces
cuando la gente hace proyectos se
imagina otra cosa y se deja
la mugre
gracias a los palos
[Aplausos]